there's a major hearing today in the
case of a young Wisconsin woman accused
of murdering her ex-boyfriend Ezra
McCandless admits she killed Alex
Woodworth but claims it was self-defense
she tells a story of being attacked and
fighting for her life but prosecutors
say that story is a lie CBS News
correspondent Jamie yuccas investigates
for 48 hours on March 22nd 2018 into my
house and somebody attacked her a
bruised and distraught stranger showed
up on the doorstep of Wisconsin dairy
farmer Don simple this police dashcam
recorded the voice of 20 year old Ezra
McCandless as she pleaded for help
[Laughter]
Azra told authorities she didn't recall
much about the attack but she knew who
attacked her a man named Alex Woodworth
Ezra was an aspiring artist who used her
own car as a canvas
Alex hoped to become a philosophy
professor the two had been having a
secret affair for months and tensions
were running high something horrible
happened to this woman district attorney
Andrea no Dolf says police had a big
problem they could not find the crime
scene or Alex police visited Alex's
house called his cell phone and spoke
with his parents but Alex had vanished
then the cops found the muddy footprints
Ezra left when she went to that dairy
farm everything changed when law
enforcement found the body
Alex wood wears body was found in
Asura's abandoned car he'd been stabbed
16 times is this the way the car was
found yes
Alex's body was kind of laying out of
the backseat when detectives confronted
Ezra she admitted to repeatedly stabbing
Alex but said it was in self-defense
after examining the evidence
investigators felt Ezra was lying this
was someone who was staging a crime
scene she was arrested and charged with
murder
this was anger and rage and this was
personal at her trial last October Ezra
McCandless testified in her own defense
although she faced a possible life
sentence at times she seemed to bask in
the limelight she's here to put on the
show for the jury this case boiled down
to whether you believed as where
McCandless or not it was there any doubt
Ezra committed this crime there was some
doubt I mean if you look at her
appearance she was somebody who when she
came into the courtroom she really kind
of lit up in the courtroom and she had
this kind of meek timid persona and the
prosecutors were very concerned that she
may come across that way and that people
would believe her story that you know
she was attacked and this awful thing
happened she would dress very feminine
in the courtroom she was somebody to
where her ex boyfriend actually said on
the stand the games never stopped so
what game was she gonna play when she
took the stand I'll be watching
all right Jamie thank you you can see
Jamie's report the case against Ezra
McCandless tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS